well as promised we want to end tonight  on andrew cuomo the governor of new york  trying to be the most masculine cuomo on  television he announced he was thinking  about  punching donald trump this year sounds  pretty tough right punching the  president united states right in the  face  and he would have done it if he hadn't  inherited his father's job as governor  watch i needed  him to help new york that was my job  if i wasn't governor of new york i would  have decked him  period i mean he was attacking me he was  attacking my family he was the  anti-italian he was every nasty  thing you know you if i take away that  word governor  for 24 hours i would have had a field  day with him  he's anti-italian now everybody's an  aggrieved victim  even governor cuomo